* Hupen *
* Fliessender Indie-Rock-Song *
# Don't look at me like this,
hun, don't be upset.
# What a wonderful day.
# Don't be mad at me
because I feel alright.
# I can't be happy
if you're not alright.
# Don't worry
cause I really feel alright.
# I go to the USA.
* Donnergrollen *
Blitz?
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Architekt Roger ist immer
auf der Suche nach guten Plänen.
Er hat gerade
einen überraschenden Anruf bekommen.
Ein junger Bauunternehmer
braucht sein Know-how.
Er ist zu spät. Er richtet sich
nicht nach Schweizer Zeit.
Ich gebe ihm bis genau 14 Uhr.
Jetzt ist ... 13.50 Uhr.
Und dann gehen wir weiter.
Schweizerisch.
You're late.
You snooze, you lose.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Sag mir, was auch immer du
hier machen willst oder musst.
Ist das nicht kalt in Shorts?
Ich friere mir den Arsch ab.
Wie heisst du?
- Tony.
Freut mich, Pat.
Ich bin Bauunternehmer und
wurde vom neuen Besitzer beauftragt.
Wir machen hier grössere Arbeiten:
Küchen, Bäder.
Wir machen das Haus Nummer 25
und das Poolhäuschen.
Du wirst uns also häufig sehen.
- Klingt gut.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Wie lange brauchst du für die Pläne?
Ich weiss nicht.
Schaffst du's bis Donnerstag?
Ich versuch's,
kann aber nichts versprechen.
Wenn du alles ausmisst und
die Fotos bis Montag machen kannst.
Ich mach's bis heute Abend.
Das ist unmöglich.
Ich krieg das ziemlich schnell hin.
Das ist typisch L.A.
Okay, das nächste Haus.
Siehst du das Haus dort oben?
Ein Bombenhaus - sie haben es
aufgegeben wegen der Bewilligung
und wegen finanzieller
Schwierigkeiten mit dem Eigentümer.
Hold on, one of these doors is open.
Vielleicht sollte ich mit einem
meiner Investoren darüber reden.
Das Einzige, was bleibt,
sind die oberen Schränke.
Die streichen wir,
und der Rest kommt raus.
Drei Zimmer bleiben, wie sie sind.
Ein Badezimmer.
Fällt hier die Hauptarbeit an?
Ja, das meiste ist hier nötig.
Schick mir das zuerst.
Und dann legen wir los.
Genial, super.
Ich mach mich an die Arbeit. Ich
schicke dir eine Zeichnung, okay?
Ja.
Die Pläne sind relativ einfach
zu erstellen, aber zeitaufwendig.
Weil bereits Donnerstag ist, ist
das wahrscheinlich nicht machbar.
Aber na ja, ich habe mal Ja gesagt.
Er muss mir noch Sachen liefern.
Er sagte, das schaffe er bis morgen.
Ich behauptete,
bis morgen sei unmöglich.
Wenn er es nicht schafft, muss ich
meine Deadline nicht einhalten.
Ich weiss jetzt schon,
dass er es nicht schafft.
Er hat gute connections, aber es
ist auch eine connection mit ihm.
Wir hatten mal einen gemeinsamen
Job. And we kinda like each other.
Wir suchen einfach
ein etwas grösseres Projekt.
Wir besorgen einander Aufträge
und schauen, wie es läuft.
You know, go from there.
Aber im Endeffekt
haben wir beide gute connections.
So kann man wachsen.
* Treibende Western-Klänge *
* Heitere, leichte Klänge *
Nach wochenlangem Renovieren,
Aufpolieren und Reparieren
die Gretchen-Frage: Werden die Käufer
sich die Klinke in die Hand geben?
Nice to meet you.
* Stimmengewirr *
* Bellen *
Dora, sehr erfreut.
Und wer sind Sie?
Amy.
- Amy. Dora. Und mein Mann Pasqual.
Hey.
David?
Und der Name deiner Schwester?
Adele.
- Adele? Wie die Sängerin.
Yes.
Sie sind süss.
Wir wohnten 15 Jahre in diesem Haus.
Jetzt kehren wir
in die Heimat zurück.
Deshalb verkaufen Sie das Haus?
- Ja, wir haben hier keine Familie.
Gute Entscheidung.
Schauen Sie sich das Haus doch an.
Den Kindern gefällt es.
Wir suchen genau so ein Haus,
v.a. weil die Kinder rauskönnen.
Den ganzen Tag drinnen,
auch in der Schule, ist nicht ideal.
Stimmt. Und hier
ist es sehr sicher und ruhig.
Another house in the back ...
That's now allowed, too.
A one-bedroom house in the back.
Guten Tag. Kommen Sie herein!
Wir lassen Sie
das Haus allein besichtigen.
Thank you.
- I'll be out of the way.
Ich habe noch nie so viele Leute
bei einer Besichtigung gesehen.
Um zu verhindern, dass die Hunde
die Interessenten vertreiben,
taucht das Paar
bei einer Freundin unter.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Schnapsidee oder weiser Entschluss?
Lauriane legt Prüfung um Prüfung ab.
Wir sind hier
beim Department of Motor Vehicles.
Ich mache jetzt die schriftliche
Prüfung für meinen Führerschein.
Seit vier Jahren versuche ich,
den Schein in der Schweiz zu machen.
Verkehrskundeunterricht
und Nothelferkurs habe ich besucht,
die Theorieprüfung zweimal gemacht.
Ich musste wiederholen.
Ich habe ca. 25 Fahrstunden genommen
und 2'000 Fr. investiert.
Ich bin sicher zu perfektionistisch.
Ich sage mir:
"Noch fahre ich nicht perfekt,
also warte ich noch zu
mit der Prüfung."
Es ist teuer
und ich hatte nicht mehr viel Geld.
Hier kostet es gesamthaft 36 $.
Wenn ich durchfalle,
kostet es 6 Fr. fürs Wiederholen.
Ich könnte schon am nächsten Tag
wieder antreten.
Es ist hier viel einfacher,
da es Automatikautos sind.
Und ich kann den Schein einfach
in der Schweiz umschreiben lassen.
Deshalb ist das ein guter Plan.
Ich bin unter Druck.
Ich habe gegen Mitternacht
mit Lernen begonnen
und durchgemacht bis 4 Uhr.
Bis vor 5 Min.
Ich rechne mit 1 Std. Schlange
stehen und 1 Std. Prüfung.
Ich hoffe, es geht gut, denn es
sind viele rechtliche Fragen dabei,
z.B. die Höhe der Franchise
bei Fahrzeugversicherungen
oder die höchstmögliche Busse.
Daumen drücken
und hoffen, dass es klappt.
* Entschlossene rockige Klänge *
Geht das so?
Ich hier und du unter mir.
Entschuldige.
- Du kannst meine Brüste anfassen.
Mist, ich begrapsche sie.
So gross sind sie ja nicht, du
kannst die Berührung gut vermeiden.
Francesca und ihre Freundinnen
basteln an ihrem Liebesleben.
Ihr buntes Ausstellungsprojekt
nimmt Form an.
Wir sind alles Frauen,
die in Los Angeles leben,
aber wir sind auch alle Mütter -
und v.a. Künstlerinnen.
Es brauchte ein Thema,
und die Liebe, die Liebe zur Kunst,
die Nächstenliebe, die Liebe
zur Stadt, das ist spannend.
Ich arbeite sehr oft allein, aber
die Idee, zusammen auszustellen,
kam ganz natürlich.
Der Solidaritätsgedanke
ist stark,
und die Lust, sich gegenseitig zu
helfen, sich aneinander zu reiben,
das haben wir schnell aufgegriffen.
Und das ist super.
Da ist der Bauchnabel
und da hört der Arm auf.
Ja.
Wir haben den ganzen Tag gebraucht,
um zuerst
verschiedene Cadavres Exquis
und dann daraus
ein kleines Fanmagazin zu machen.
Das ist der Tag, an dem wir
etwas Kollaboratives machen,
aus dem vielleicht dann etwas wird.
Mal sehen.
* Französischer Reggae-Song *
Fang hier an!
Schau, wie viel Platz du hast.
Entweder bis da
oder ein bisschen tiefer.
Unsere künstlerische Praxis
beruht tatsächlich auf Liebe,
die heftig sein kann,
leidenschaftlich,
die nicht zwingend leicht
oder sanft sein muss.
Sie kann stürmisch sein, wie wenn
du verliebt bist, leidenschaftlich.
Wir sind alle multidimensional,
so wie Frauen und die Liebe
nun mal sind.
* Englisches Telefongespräch *
L.A. ist eine knallharte Stadt.
Es ist hart, hier zu bleiben,
hier zu leben.
Die Leute sind hier,
um zu arbeiten, um Geld zu machen,
um erfolgreich zu sein.
Wenn einer dich grüsst,
denkt er sofort daran,
was für ihn herausspringen könnte.
Das ist anstrengend.
Du machst die Füsse mit den Beinen.
An dem Teil hast du
nicht gearbeitet. Mach ihm Füsse!
Los jetzt, mach ihm Füsse!
Welchen Teil hast du
noch nicht gemalt? Den?
Doch. Den da habe ich gemacht.
* Treibende Elektro-Klänge *
# Dance, dance, dance.
Eins, zwei, drei.
Wow!
This is great.
* Langsame einzelne Western-Klänge *
Dora und Pasqual
haben Unterschlupf gefunden
bei ihrer alten Freundin Patty.
Hallo, Patty.
- You okay, honey?
Das ist lustig. - Ich kaufe
dir einen. Die machen Spass.
Vielleicht
mache ich ein anderes Muster.
Ich habe ein Haus nur für Hunde.
Alles in diesem Haus ist für sie:
diese zwei Türen, dieses Fenster.
I ... It's a doggy house.
Zu Patty gehen wir,
wenn wir aus dem Haus müssen.
Als es auf unserem Hügel brannte,
sind wir zu Patty. Stimmt's?
Absolut.
Wir haben hier einige Nächte
verbracht, bevor wir zurückkonnten.
Und heute sind wir hier
wegen der Hausbesichtigungen.
Patty und eine andere Freundin
gehörten zu den Gypsies,
einer professionellen Tanztruppe,
die in Filmen und am Broadway
auftrat.
Eines Tages hat Patty gesagt:
"Dora braucht einen Mann."
Sie hat ein Rendezvous arrangiert
und so haben wir uns kennengelernt.
Kurz darauf hat mir Dora
einen Heiratsantrag gemacht.
Natürlich
glauben wir den letzten Teil.
Wenn du glauben willst, dass ich
um deine Hand angehalten habe,
dann ist das okay.
Damals war sie
sehr zurückhaltend und ruhig.
Später hat sie die Kontrolle
übernommen. Da war's vorbei.
Du bist unmöglich.
Ich hasse es, dich gehen zu lassen.
Das ist mein Problem.
Komm uns doch
in der Schweiz besuchen.
Ja, ich komme vorbei.
- Wir schreiben uns. Mails und SMS.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Ich habe gerade 2 Std. Prüfungen
hinter mir. Und ich habe bestanden.
Ich bin glücklich.
Wir mussten lange warten.
Ich musste Tausende Visa zeigen,
Tausende Dokumente vorlegen,
da ich ja keine Amerikanerin bin.
Aber die Prüfung war super kurz.
Der nächste Schritt ist,
einen Fahrlehrer zu finden -
falls ich keinen Amerikaner finde,
der bereit ist,
gratis mit mir rumzufahren.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Auf Wiedersehen, Patty.
Wir sehen uns bald wieder.
Es wird Zeit, heimzukehren.
Der Nachmittag geht zu Ende.
Die Besichtigungen sind vorbei.
Sie warten,
bis Monica grünes Licht gibt.
* Telefon *
Hello, Monica? Hi.
Hallo, wie geht's?
Wie geht's, wie steht's?
Es ist vorbei, gut.
Wir sind auf dem Rückweg.
Gute Nachrichten?
Sie hat Angebote, die leicht über
dem festgesetzten Preis liegen.
Es gab Leute,
die gekommen sind und gesagt haben,
sie würden mehr bieten.
Jetzt können sie
gegeneinander bieten.
Sie hat wirklich getan,
was sie versprochen hat.
* Entspannte, gläserne Klänge *
Los Angeles, ein Abbild der Welt,
ein wahrhaft buntes
ethnisches Mosaik.
Klassen und Rassen
treffen zwar aufeinander,
verbrüdern sich aber nicht.
Eine Regenbogengesellschaft von Afro-
amerikanern, Chicanos und Asiaten.
Man reist um die Welt und
verlässt doch nie die Agglomeration.
Muslime fallen hier nicht auf,
was am gegenwärtigen
politischen Klima liegt.
Doch alle Religionen
konnten ihre Gotteshäuser errichten.
Nach Tel Aviv und New York
ist L.A. die drittgrösste
jüdische Stadt der Welt.
Zwei Schritte von der Synagoge
liegt dieses nicht sehr koschere
Restaurant. Es gibt Würste.
Randy ist der erste Schweizer
Footballspieler in Los Angeles.
Bemerkenswert.
Wir sind an einer Versammlung
der Swiss Mixer.
Es gibt diese Treffen,
um andere Schweizer kennenzulernen,
die in Los Angeles leben,
um Freundschaften zu schliessen,
um zu helfen,
wenn jemand etwas braucht.
Mein Vater ist Schweizer,
aus Winterthur,
meine Mutter ist Südafrikanerin.
Ich bin also vermutlich
mit Roger Federer verwandt.
Ich kann nicht jeden Monat dabei
sein. Das erlaubt mein Job nicht.
Oft muss ich arbeiten,
wenn sie sich treffen.
Manchmal fehlt mir die Schweiz.
Wir alle haben so ein Gefühl
von Heimweh.
Wir organisieren diese Treffen,
um uns der Schweiz näher zu fühlen -
dank des Essens, dank der Freunde.
* Sanfte Klänge *
Pacific Palisades
im Westen der Stadt.
In diesem Wohnviertel
kamen die Deutschen unter,
die vor den Nazis geflohen waren,
wie Literaturnobelpreisträger
Thomas Mann.
Das Viertel, das in den 1920er-Jahren
von Methodisten gegründet wurde,
hat sich komplett verändert.
Die Bungalows von damals
sind Luxusvillen gewichen.
Hey.
- How are you?
Come on in.
- Good seeing you.
We just want it to be on center.
- Yeah, on center.
Then, we need to fix
the little things outside.
Dieses Haus wurde 1962 erbaut.
Vor zehn Jahren
hat es mein Kunde gekauft.
Als Mid-century-Haus.
Es war ganz dunkel
und, you know, also,
damp, im Inneren.
Wir haben es dann komplett umgebaut,
aber den Charakter
des Mid-century-Hauses bewahrt.
Mid-century-Häuser sind in den
50er- bis 60er-Jahren entstanden,
als Low-budget-Häuser.
Es waren Experimentalhäuser.
D.h. viel offener space, viel Glas
und eine ganz einfach Konstruktion.
Die Gegend
wurde in den 60er-Jahren aufgebaut
von einem einzigen developer.
Er kreierte hier oben
einzelne Parzellen.
Die musste man günstig halten,
da niemand
in Pacific Palisades wohnen wollte:
zu weit weg von den Hotspots,
wo man arbeitet.
Jetzt ist es genau umgekehrt:
Es ist sehr exclusive, die Mid-
century-Häuser sind sehr gesucht.
Vor vier Jahren hat der Kunde
das Haus unten dran gekauft.
Wir bauten einen Tunnel,
um von diesem Haus
ins andere zu gelangen.
Das Gesetz schreibt vor:
Der Charakter des Quartiers
muss bewahrt werden.
Von aussen muss es immer aussehen,
als wären es zwei Häuser.
Das Wort Tunnel
kam bei der Stadt nicht so gut an.
Es dauerte eineinhalb Jahre, bis wir
überhaupt die Baubewilligung hatten.
Man findet immer irgendeine Lösung.
Man muss halt
mit der Stadt spielen.
Statt Tunnel nannten wir es
am Schluss "hallway",
obwohl es eigentlich ein Tunnel ist.
Man soll nicht merken,
dass das eine Garage ist.
Wenn du hier stehst,
weisst du nicht,
wo die Garagentüre ist
oder wo man mit dem Auto reinfährt.
Das war eigentlich das Ziel.
Es ist heikel, denn man muss
mit den Fahrzeugen rein und raus.
Der Raum soll funktionieren,
aber nicht riechen.
Roger wusste,
was geht und was nicht.
Und wie man dieses Haus
zu etwas Modernem umbaut.
Das kann nur einer: Roger.
In einem Einfamilienhaus
hast du nur Anrecht auf eine Küche.
Aber weil die Distanz
zwischen hier und dort so gross ist,
wollten wir hier eine kleine Küche
machen. Das ist nicht erlaubt.
Wir mussten tricksen
und haben behauptet,
dass es eine koschere Küche ist,
was erlaubt ist.
Eine normale Küche
und eine koschere Küche
in einem Einfamilienhaus geht,
aber nicht zwei gleiche.
Und sie haben nicht nachgefragt.
Nein, sie wollten nichts wissen.
Sie fragen nicht,
ob du Jude oder Moslem bist.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Ja, wir gehen rauf.
Werden Dora und Pasqual mit
leichtem Herzen und vollen Taschen
in die Schweiz zurückkehren?
- Die Stunde der Wahrheit.
Hallo. Wie geht's?
Dora, how are you this morning?
- How are you? Good to see you.
Good to see you, too.
Wie fühlst du dich heute Morgen?
- Nervös.
Beruhige dich. Sag, mit
wie vielen Angeboten rechnest du?
Zwei.
Das ist nicht die Anzahl,
die wir erhalten haben.
Wir haben elf Angebote bekommen.
- Wow.
Ab 520 und zwei für 550.
Zwei für 550?
- Zwei Topangebote.
Das ist fantastisch.
Das kannst du laut sagen.
Ich hatte viel mehr Angebote
zum Basispreis erwartet.
Davor hatte ich am meisten Angst.
Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Fantastisch.
Ich war sehr skeptisch, als sie es
für 499 auf den Markt brachte.
Ich vertraute ihr nicht.
Ich sagte immer:
"Nein, die werden weniger bieten,
als wir wollen."
Es ist gut. Sie hatte recht.
Das ist typisch für Leute,
die ihr Haus verkaufen wollen.
Sie glauben, dass du bei einem
höheren Preis keinen Käufer findest
oder dass du verhandeln und ihn
nach unten korrigieren musst.
Sie kann das nicht verstehen,
da es nicht ihr Beruf ist.
Sie unterrichtet Ballett.
Das können wir nicht begreifen,
vertrauen ihr aber.
Und in diesem Fall
hat sie mir vertraut.
Ich war etwas besorgt,
weil ich sehe,
wie der Markt
in vielen Vierteln einbricht.
Darum habe ich
ihr nicht alles gesagt.
Ich wollte nicht,
dass sie in Panik ausbricht.
Das ist mein Job, und ich wollte die
Zielsetzung erreichen, ihren Preis.
Sie ist meine
Lieblingsballettlehrerin.
Überhaupt ist sie mir die Liebste
in meinem Leben.
Sie hat mir meinen Körper gegeben,
weil sie mich trainiert hat.
Danke.
Sie ist ein Vorbild für mich.
So hart zu arbeiten, in ihrem Alter.
Alle ihre Schüler/-innen lieben sie
über alles, nicht nur ich.
Ich bin glücklich,
ihr helfen zu können.
Mein Ziel war, ihr Freude
zu bereiten, mein Bestes zu geben,
um ihr das zurückzugeben,
was sie für mich getan hat.
Okay, I'll bring you ... out.
Auf Wiedersehen, Dora.
Du spielst richtig gut Minigolf.
Du kannst spielen kommen,
wann immer du willst.
* Entspannter R'n'B-Song *
Ob als Stürmer oder Verteidiger,
Randys Herz
lebt nur für den American Football.
Meine Leidenschaft für Football
geht auf das Jahr 1983 zurück,
als wir in Lugano
die Lugano Seagulls gegründet haben.
Ich habe mich
sofort in diesen Sport verliebt
und immer davon geträumt,
in Amerika zu spielen.
Fast von Anfang an habe ich hier
bei den California Bandits gespielt,
ab den 90er-Jahren.
Wir haben dreimal die
nationalen Meisterschaften gewonnen.
Ich bin einer der Schweizer Spieler,
die in den Staaten professionell
Football gespielt haben.
Vor zwei Jahren wurde ich
in die Hall of Fame aufgenommen -
das Grösste überhaupt für mich,
eine riesige Anerkennung,
die mich sehr glücklich gemacht hat.
In der Ruhmeshalle als bester Spie-
ler der Geschichte geehrt zu werden,
das ist fantastisch,
das hat mich sehr gefreut.
Als Football-Spieler muss ich mich
schützen. In meinem Alter.
Ich versuche,
meine Knie zu schützen,
die Fesseln,
die Ellbogen.
Als Lineman trage ich Handschuhe,
Schulterschoner
und natürlich einen Helm.
Die meisten der Spieler
sind zwischen 20 und 30 Jahre alt.
Ich bin 54 und damit der älteste
aktive Spieler Kaliforniens.
The SpeedFlex too, okay?
So, with this one you open it.
- With that one?
And this one, okay, to remove.
Das ist für dich.
- Danke.
Im Sportlerparadies
sind alle Fussballer willkommen.
Das stärkt den Teamgeist -
und nur der zählt hier.
Wir holen die Kinder
vom Nachwuchstraining ab.
Es ist ihr letztes Training.
Wir wollen Tristans Fussballtrainer
sehen, der weggeht.
Wir wurden eingeladen
und sind gekommen.
Es ist eine internationale Schule,
die sich an den französischen
und amerikanischen Lehrplan hält.
Der französische beinhaltet mehr
Geschichte als der amerikanische.
Sie sollen eine breite
Allgemeinbildung bekommen.
Das war sehr gut.
Ich mag den Lehrer.
Er ist sehr nett.
Ich bringe die Kinder zur Schule,
fahre zu meinem Atelier
und stelle den Wecker.
Der klingelt dann.
Ich hole die Kinder ab,
fahre nach Hause, mache Essen.
Normaler Alltag halt.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Heute spielen wir Fussball.
Anja hat das vorgeschlagen.
Leider weiss ich nicht,
ob ich besser hätte absagen sollen.
Ich tendiere dazu, super motiviert
und aufgedreht zu sein,
wenn man mir etwas vorschlägt.
Sofort zusagen, ohne zu überlegen.
Aber dann hab ich realisiert,
dass ich morgen eine Prüfung habe
und eigentlich nie Fussball spiele.
Ich habe das letzte Mal
mit 14 Fussball gespielt -
und zwar nicht freiwillig, während
der obligatorischen Schulzeit.
Mir ist nicht ganz wohl dabei.
Ich hätte das Kino oder ein
Restaurant vorschlagen sollen.
Hey.
- Hey.
Wie geht's?
- Gut, und dir?
Das ist Anthon, ein Freund.
Sehr erfreut.
- Sehr erfreut, Lauriane.
Im Kino oder im Ausgang hätten
Lauriane und ihre Freundin Anja
diese Begegnung sicher nie gehabt.
Darf ich Sie bitten,
ein Foto von uns zu machen?
Thank you.
Del Piero.
Ja, das sagt mir etwas.
Er ist sehr bekannt, oder?
- Ja, super bekannt.
Wir haben
Alessandro Del Piero gesehen.
Er ist sehr berühmt gewesen
vor ein paar Jahren.
Das war cool.
Viele meiner Freunde
sind Fussballfans.
Es wird sie rasend machen,
wenn sie das Foto bekommen.
Auch Anja spielt Fussball, als
Verteidigerin in einem Genfer Club.
Es tut gut, nach dem Unterricht
den Kopf freizukriegen.
Weil gerade Prüfungszeit ist,
sind wir so wenige.
Ich setze mich voll ein, weil ich
gewinnen will. Mit Kampfgeist.
Aber leider bin ich
mit den Füssen nicht gut genug.
Basketball
wäre wohl besser für mich.
Aber es tut gut.
Ich kann mich austoben.
Wenn du den ganzen Tag in der
Bibliothek bist, um zu lernen,
tut das richtig gut.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
Geht's gut, Milo?
- Ja.
Regarde, regarde!
Bonjour, bonjour.
Lernst du Mathe?
- Ja.
Brauchst du das für morgen?
- Für Montag.
Und verstehst du's oder nicht?
Es geht, ich muss noch die Rückseite
machen, und das hier auch noch.
Kalkulisieren.
Kalkulieren.
Und hast du das hier gemacht?
Noch nicht.
- Okay.
Ich wollte erst das machen,
weil es leichter ist.
Okay, gut.
Wie geht's deinem Handgelenk?
- Geht so.
Super. Danke,
dass du mir das alles gezeigt hast.
Ja.
Du schuftest richtig.
Ich kenne nicht viele Klischees
über die Schweizer.
Aber ich weiss, dass sie
sehr genau sind, immer pünktlich.
Und jedes Mal, wenn ich Mama bitte,
etwas für mich zu machen,
dann macht sie es auch.
Bei meinem Vater hingegen
ist das nicht immer garantiert.
Manchmal vergisst er es.
Meine Mutter hingegen
denkt immer an alles.
Die meisten meiner Freunde
haben keine Künstler als Eltern.
Mama und Papa haben mir geholfen,
meine Leidenschaft für die Musik
zu entdecken.
Und es ist toll, dass sie mich
bei allem unterstützen,
was mir Spass macht.
Meine Eltern ...
Ich mag, was ihnen gefällt, aber
ich verhalte mich nicht wie sie.
Meine Persönlichkeit
ist nicht so wie ihre.
Sie sind recht streng, wenn es
um meine Noten und die Schule geht,
aber bei anderen Dingen eher nicht.
Auch bei der Zeit,
die ich vorm Bildschirm verbringe,
sind sie streng, aber das ist okay.
Tristan ...
Hein?
Yeah?
Hast du die Hausaufgaben gemacht?
Bei dir
liegen lauter Socken auf dem Boden.
Ich habe einen Bucheinband gemacht.
Ein Bucheinband?
Für wen?
Für das Buch, das ich
mit meinen Freunden gemacht habe.
"101 Arten,
ein Hotdog-Wettessen zu gewinnen".
Schön. Ich mag es,
wenn du witzige Sachen machst.
Das ist super.
In zehn Jahren sehe ich mich
mit einer Musikausbildung
irgendwo in der Musikbranche.
In L.A. wird es früh Nacht,
aber man arbeitet bis spät.
Du versprichst mir was
und machst es dann nicht.
Deshalb rufe ich dich an.
Was ist los?
Okay, fahr hin!
Sei so nett und fang innen an.
Aber beweg deinen Hintern!
Auch ich muss Sachen machen,
auf die ich keine Lust habe.
Das gehört nun mal zum Leben.
Wenn dir ein Amerikaner
keine richtige Antwort geben kann,
ruft er dich niemals an und sagt:
"Ich weiss es nicht."
Er ruft dich einfach nicht an.
Er hätte mich
heute Morgen um 8 Uhr anrufen sollen
und hat es nicht gemacht.
Ich weiss nicht, wie viele Nach-
richten ich ihm hinterlassen habe.
Er ruft mich einfach nicht zurück,
weil er keine Antwort weiss.
Wenn du
bis Freitag nicht fertig bist,
feuere ich dich
und stelle jemand anderen ein.
Und du kommst für die Zusatzkosten
auf. Mach es endlich!
Aber das ist heute überall so: Jeder
will Geld machen mit Nichtstun.
Jeder will Geld machen,
ohne zu arbeiten.
Aber so funktioniert das nicht.
Wobei:
Für einige funktioniert das doch.
... YouTube guys, die Geld machen
wie blöd und nicht arbeiten müssen.
Schon gut ...
It's not, but anyway.
Du musst einfach manchmal ein
bisschen tough sein mit den Leuten.
Die arbeiten nur,
wenn du nicht immer lieb bist,
sondern auch mal sagst: "Hey!
Ich brauche es jetzt, okay?"
"Fertig Bullshit!"
Ich habe viel Geduld,
bis der Geduldsfaden reisst.
Dann habe ich keine Geduld mehr und
bin kein friedlicher Mensch mehr.
Aber eigentlich
bin ich sehr friedlich.
Früher konnte man
mit weniger Projekten überleben.
Während der letzten zehn Jahre ...
fünf bis zehn Jahre
ist das Leben hier in Los Angeles
extrem teuer geworden.
Die Mieten sind wie in der Stadt
Zürich - wohl sogar höher.
Das war vorher nicht der Fall.
Ich bezahle lieber mehr und muss
dafür nicht 1 1/2 Std. Auto fahren.
Jetzt ist später Abend, da will ich
keinen Heimweg von 1 Std.,
sondern will
in 10 Min. zu Hause sein.
Diese Möglichkeit zu haben,
ist in Los Angeles selten.
Das ist eigentlich ein Glücksfall.
Schönen Abend.
* Einsame Westerngitarre *
* Funkige Klänge *
Endlich betritt Randy die Arena. Der
Älteste, der Erfahrenste, ein Star.
Randy erntet bewundernde Blicke,
von den Spielern, dem Coach,
dem Kommentator und dem Publikum.
Let's go!
Come on, let's go!
* Rufe *
* Pfiff *
Es ist das beste Spiel der Welt.
Mann gegen Mann, Gladiatoren.
Das wurde früher in einer römischen
Arena gespielt, mit Löwen und Bären.
Heute wird
mit Kerlen wie diesen hier gespielt.
* Schrille Trillerpfeife *
Älter werden ist hart für uns alle.
Ich verstehe nicht, wie er
noch all diese Dinge machen kann.
Wenn du in seinem Alter noch
auf diesem Niveau spielen kannst,
dann ist das ein Geschenk Gottes.
Ich hoffe, dass Randy
uns noch lange erhalten bleibt,
auch wenn er dann nicht mehr selber
spielt. Die Jungs brauchen ihn.
* Schleppender Rap-Song *
In all den Jahren habe ich mir
schon alles Mögliche gebrochen.
Die Finger, den Daumen,
beide Fesseln, das Knie.
Ich hatte eine durchlöcherte Lunge.
Im Moment habe ich Rückenschmerzen.
Es ist ein gefährlicher Sport.
* Langsamer Sprechgesang *
* Rufe *
Das ist das Feld der Träume,
Land der Magie, Heim der Stars.
Wir haben hier
viele Stars auf dem Feld gesehen.
Und der Typ da, Randy Danner? Mein
Gott. Vor Randy zieh ich meinen Hut.
Ich bin sehr gerührt, weil
ich weiss, dass ich aufhören muss.
Ich bin traurig,
weil ich weiterspielen möchte.
Aber ich weiss,
dass ich das nicht mehr kann.
Gleichzeitig bin ich glücklich
und froh, weil ich weiss,
dass ich dem Sport verbunden bleibe,
den ich mein ganzes Leben lang
geliebt habe.
Es ist ein Kampf Mann gegen Mann,
wie bei den Gladiatoren.
So ist nicht nur dieser Sport, son-
dern auch das Leben in Los Angeles:
Man muss schubsen, ausweichen,
rangeln und loslegen.
Und immer in Bewegung bleiben.
Das habe ich quasi
als escape place von L.A. gekauft.
Es ist gut für die Seele.
Ich hoffe, die Schranke geht auf.
Hier ist niemand und da auch nicht.
Turn right, right, but
there's ... Da drüben sind Kinder.
Heute ist die Oscar-Verleihung.
Jetzt dürfen wir nicht mehr filmen,
stopp.